banier ouais on va préparer les
commandes pour les oeufs comme tous les
matins c'est l'effervescence dans cette
épicerie familiale
le va et vient des clients a laissé
place aux bruits des feuilles
d'aluminium les en toile y fasse une
bonne partie du temps à emballer des
plateaux 2 depuis le confinement
cette épicerie spécialisée en produits
sicilien a décidé de venir en aide à
certains producteurs locaux
ces derniers se trouvant dans
l'impossibilité d'écouler leur
production
en fait ce moule et on avait un éleveur
talib baudet malheureusement ils ceux
qui vantent la production est en fait un
bond en arrière pour la vente de ces
oeufs l'épicerie n'empoche aucun
bénéfice sa gérante a également voulu
venir en aide au personnel soignant
leurs commandes sont livrées
gratuitement et ce n'est pas tout on
s'est dit que pour apporter un soutien
aussi au personnel médical et vu leur
horaire très décalé qu'on était à leur
portée pour même ouvrir le magasin sis
ii faut pour pour qu'ils viennent
chercher
leur métier ou leur apporter en
livraison bien sûr qu'on fait pour tout
le monde gratuitement et 10 pour faire
pour les italiens les employés préparent
aussi des plats chauds peu à peu
l'épicerie s'est transformé en véritable
traiteur pour ce qui est des livraisons
c'est alex qui s'en charge
dès la fin de la matinée il entame un
véritable ballet d'allers retours pour
charger la voiture et livrer les clients
mais pour le moment j'ai pris seulement
plutôt des courses des petites produits
du sud
beaucoup de gens qui les aiment ces
produits donc on essaie de quand même
faire sortir moi les gens de la maison
malgré les difficultés à travailler en
plein confinement cette épicerie réussi
à maintenir son activité tout en faisant
preuve de solidarité
la boutique a même gagné en clientèle